here's what would happen if you were  born on the moon  right now a moon base is only  hypothetical you'd begin life in a  state-of-the-art base surrounded by  astronauts but here comes the fun part  earth birth is no walk in the park but  the moon's lower gravity would have made  your bird even more challenging as a  fetus you'd develop more slowly than you  would on earth so your mother would have  to carry you inside her for one full  year all moon babies would be born  through c-section  that means moonlings may evolve to have  bigger heads than babies from earth  the moonborn would also need to adapt to  the sun's radiation resulting in  potentially darker or lighter skin tones  than we would see on earth  you'd have to watch your contact with  new astronauts or earthborn settlers  visitors could bring infections to your  base and the last thing we need is a  moon pandemic so